[Música]
o que você sabe
essa pergunta ela não é na verdade o que
você sabe sobre o tema que vou falar
sobre o ted
mas na verdade a pergunta é o que você
aprendeu ao longo da sua vida
qual o arcabouço de informações que você
conseguiu juntar ao longo da sua
trajetória
você considera ele suficiente é ele
atualmente um conhecimento suficiente
para sua vida para sua carreira
você está satisfeito com a velocidade
que você está aprendendo está a sua
capacidade de aprender e voltar e
retornar a aprender você está aprendendo
algo agora neste momento ou quem sabe no
último mês
quem sabe no último ano me perdoem ser
tão provocativo mas essas perguntas e
esses questionamentos são bem
pertinentes para a idéia que eu quero
passar aqui e permitam mais uma em algum
momento vocês pararam se depararam e
perceberam ou pensaram que estão
aprendendo bem menos do que deveriam
eu estou aprendendo estou deixando
passar muitas oportunidades de
conhecimento que deveria ter adquirido e
não estou conseguindo por algum motivo
que não importa neste momento qual seja
eu não consigo aprender aquele
conhecimento adquirir aquela informação
não sei vocês mas eu por várias vezes na
minha vida já me percebi pensando assim
e se alguém aqui está na mesma posição
que eu já não se preocupe porque isso é
muito comum de acontecer isso tem
acontecido muito na verdade nos tempos
atuais
nós chamamos isso de débitos do
aprendizado débitos no aprendizado fica
o que é que existe um conjunto de
conhecimentos que você deveria estar
adquirindo mas não está
e você está querendo uma dívida vários
débitos de aprendizado e construindo um
saldo negativo que você em algum momento
necessita reembolsar depositar acreditar
para que você realmente possa ser o
melhor profissional na sua carreira e a
melhor pessoa na sua vida
eu sempre digo que depois do aprendizado
podem ser causados por falta de
dedicação mas também podem ser causados
talvez por indisciplina mas eu quero
defender que um novo fator o fator novo
que eu acredito que seja causando
débitos de aprendizado nessa geração pra
explicar melhor esse novo fator
eu preciso contar um pouquinho de uma
história que aconteceu há alguns anos
atrás
em 1989 no famosíssimo cern centro
europeu de pesquisa nuclear
tim bernes lee inventou algo incrível
algo fantástico que foi a web o maior e
mais difundido e usado serviço da
internet
nessa época a internet já existia ela
tinha 30 anos de existência mas ainda
não existe nenhum mecanismo nenhuma
tecnologia vinculado à internet que
permitisse a propagação ea disso ea
disponibilidade de disponibilização
desculpa de dados em escala mundial
tim bernes lee foi o grande responsável
pela criação dessa tecnologia e hoje nós
somos resultados daquilo que aconteceu
em 89
hoje nós estamos vendo o que a web se
tornou em pouco tempo ela se tornou no
maior repositório de conhecimento da
humanidade
se compararmos a web hoje com grandes
outros repositórios que a humanidade já
construiu nós vamos perceber que ela tem
um pequeno diferencial
estou comparando aí as três maiores
bibliotecas do mundo
a biblioteca de nova york que tem 53
milhões de exemplares de documentos
a biblioteca de londres que tem 150
milhões ea biblioteca a maior biblioteca
do mundo a biblioteca do congresso
americano em washington que tem 155
milhões de documentos
percebo é ficar lá que elas são
completamente irrelevantes ao comparadas
com a google que possui cerca de 1
trilhão de documento
santos indexados e a google não é a web
toda é só uma parte da web que a google
conseguiu indexar e catalogar percebeu
então que existe um diferencial muito
grande por algum motivo
nós conseguimos agora criar conteúdo
publicar informações difundidas
conhecimentos de uma maneira como nós
nunca antes havíamos tínhamos feito na
verdade isso nos mostra então que
estamos no momento a chave talvez assim
da nossa história
o momento onde nós estamos numa nova era
onde todos nós somos autores
o de todos nós somos escritores onde
todos nós conseguimos publicar aquilo
que estamos criando
aquilo que estamos estudando aquilo que
estamos fazendo esse novo momento da
história é interessante porque agora não
existem barreiras na verdade existe uma
ruptura de barreiras e o que essa
ruptura de barreiras
tudo que você agora pode construir não
está limitado a nenhuma restrição física
e geográfica ou nenhuma nenhum tipo de
restrição social
portanto hoje neste momento
milhões de pessoas estão criando
conteúdo milhões de documentos talvez
elas estão disponibilizando isso em
diversos canais que são consumidos pelos
mais variados dispositivos
isso é incrível e para mostrar o quanto
isso tem se tornado um magnífico
grandioso colossal
uma pesquisa da ibm mostrou que entre os
anos de 2010 e 2011
cerca de 90% de todo o conteúdo que já
tinha sido criado foi criado somente
nesses dois anos ou seja 90% de tudo o
que se ganhou do início da civilização
até o final de 2011 foi criado entre
2010 e 2011
nove vezes mais do que existir esse
mesmo estudo
national day the corporation falou
explicou que em 2020
nós teremos 350 veta bytes de
informações e tablets é uma grandeza
computacional enorme talvez muitos de
vocês não conheço mas eu tenho certeza
que conhecem e conhecem gigabytes e
colocando nessa escala em 2020
nós vamos produzir 35 trilhões de
gigabytes somente nesse ano ou seja a
cada 12 horas segundo o mesmo estudo
nós estaremos dobrando a quantidade de
informações que foi gerada
isso é muito interessante isso é
incrível mas existe um outro lado dessa
moeda porque quanto mais informações nós
estamos disponibilizando nessa rede
nessa nesse canal simples e muito fácil
de encontrar essas informações
nós estamos então criando uma quantidade
massiva de dados
uma verdadeira overdose de informação um
tsunami de informação sobre os mais
variados assuntos e o que isso causa
em nosso caso que eu chamo de sobrecarga
cognitiva agora para encontrar um
documento que está adequado à minha
demanda informacional eu vou precisar
perder muito tempo procurando entre a
vasta lista de documentos que falam
daquele assunto talvez milhões de
documentos
uma pesquisa no motor de busca pode
trazer milhões de resultados e até
encontrar a informação na profundidade
que eu preciso e levaria muito tempo e
esse tempo gasto em fazer isso gera uma
sobrecarga mental do usuário
diminuindo assim drasticamente o seu a
sua capacidade cognitiva fazendo com que
ele perca o potencial de aprender então
ele vai estar cansado mentalmente e não
vai conseguir aprender como ele poderia
se tivesse o acesso imediato à
informação que ele precisa
então o meu ponto aqui é como eu posso
aprender o que de fato precisa aprender
para não ter débitos de aprendizado
no entanto durante esse processo eu
quero evitar que eu passe por sobrecarga
cognitiva como posso evitar isso
e um dos caminhos que tens que eu tenho
estudado a respeito disso é a engenharia
cognitiva
eu sou professor desde os 21 anos de
idade professor universitário e desde
então eu tenho buscado métodos maneiras
estudos que descrevam os processos
mentais que ocorrem quando estamos
aprendendo e numa certa ocasião fui
convidado para ministrar uma disciplina
de pós graduação sobre a interface homem
computador mas por incrível que tenta
encontrar o apresentar as melhores
práticas na construção de telas de
programas de computador que sejam
facilmente aprendidas e também
facilmente utilizadas e durante esse
processo eu me deparei com uma área nova
e desconhecida que eu desconhecia que a
engenharia cognitiva
fiquei muito encantado com a área e
comecei desde então a estudar os
processos mentais as estruturas mentais
que estão relacionados ao aprendizado
aprendi muito sobre isso e eu vou falar
aqui é basicamente resultado que eu
tenho estudado sobre engenharia
cognitiva
eu queria apresentar a vocês
alguns questionamentos que me fez a
partir do momento que comecei a entrar
nos circuitos nos nos círculos que agger
e cognitiva envolveu ea primeira
pergunta é muito é muito simples mas é
um questionamento interessante porque eu
aprendo facilmente letras de músicas que
eu nunca me preocupei em aprender mas
tenham extrema dificuldade para aprender
poemas que eu gostaria muito de tê los
facilmente na minha lembrança porque eu
consigo
eu não consigo aprender frases do mês
foi o prato predileto do meu autor
predileto mas consigo facilmente lembrar
de falas de personagens de alguns filmes
durante muito tempo eu queria saber
fazer propostas não tinha agido com
objetivo me ajudou a encontrar um
caminho que talvez seja a resposta pra
isso mas o ponto agora neste momento é
existe
maneiras distintas que o cérebro aprende
não por algum motivo desconhecido até
então pra mim o cérebro poderia aprender
mas em algumas ocasiões como música que
fala de personagens e menos em outras
ocasiões como leituras de poemas e
frases escritas pelos meus autores
prediletos
eu percebi então que era necessário
decodificar decifrar a maneira que o
cérebro aprende como ele escolhe que
informação lhe traz mais facilmente e
como ele descarta as informações que ele
decidiu em não trazer facilmente a norma
vê na com qualidade suficiente e
estudando isso a ingerir coletiva
explicou que aquela região do cérebro
possui uma função específica e do mesmo
modo possui uma interpretação para os
estímulos de cada sensor de cada sentido
que nós temos e mais interessante do que
isso ainda é que cada região do nosso
cérebro quanto mais regiões do nosso
cérebro são estimulados no momento que
eu estou tendo acesso a essa informação
mais o cérebro permite ou identifica
aquela informação aquele conteúdo como
relevante ea partir daquele momento ele
se abre para armazenar aquela informação
com qualidade e ela vai estar sempre
facilmente sendo lembrada com qualidade
é por isso que a cada palavra que eu
falo aqui a cada gesto ou expressão do
meu rosto ou a cada pensamento que você
gera em relação ao que eu estou fazendo
ou a cada frase que aparece legislar de
cada cor tudo isso estimula o teu
cérebro e faz com que eu afirmei pra
você agora categoricamente que você
aprenderá esse conteúdo que estou
falando aqui com muito mais qualidade do
que se você estivesse lendo um artigo
falando as mesmas coisas porque lendo um
artigo você usaria apenas a parte do
cérebro responsável pela leitura
preto no branco mas aqui você está sendo
altamente estimulado por estímulos
sensitivos ricos
com visão audição sentimentos emoções
identificação de cores
tudo isso está sendo levado em
consideração para o cérebro por isso
consigo ouvir mais e é por isso também
que nós aprendemos facilmente as músicas
porque na experiência escutar uma música
eu uso a audição mas já começa a gerar
emoções eu começo a pensar sobre aquela
letra e isso tudo movimenta ativa
estimula muito mais regiões do cérebro
do que uma leitura de um poema
da mesma forma a assistir uma personagem
de um filme eu consigo ver a ação sem
tirar a expressão do ator escutar o que
ele está falando e isso mais uma vez
ativa muito mais regiões o meu cérebro
do que lendo um artigo com a frase
máxima do motor predileto
por isso eu acredito que para nós a
criarmos o aprendizado
nós temos que entender que existem
atalhos atalhos que nós podemos tomar
para aprender mais rapidamente
eu sou engenheiro da computação e na
minha área toda vez que nós tomamos
alguma falha ou seja para fazer algo
mais rápido ou seja pra fazer um algo
mais barato diminui o custo
nós dizemos que estamos rastreando
aquele processo
por isso o tema da palestra hackeando
aprendizado porque o que eu quero fazer
aqui é aprender mais rapidamente e para
a que é o aprendizado para criar esse
caminho que na verdade agora vai ser um
atalho
a primeira coisa que eu identifico é eu
preciso aumentar a actividade do meu
cérebro
então enquanto estou estudando no
processo de estudo de aquisição e
retenção de conhecimento eu preciso de
alguma forma mostrar para o meu cérebro
que aquela informação relevante que ela
vale a pena ser armazenada que é
importante para minha sobrevivência para
isso só existe uma maneira ativando
regiões o meu cérebro e o primeiro
atalho que eu quero indicar para que
vocês tomem para aprender mais rápido é
torna o aprendizado uma experiência
audiovisual imagens vídeos movimentos
animações áudios isso tudo ativa muito
mais regiões no seu cérebro
do que uma leitura simples a eles em
pesquisas que mostram que isso melhore
em até 89 por cento poder de retenção de
conhecimento do teu cérebro então
percebi que o primeiro ataque é muito
simples eu tenho a opção de escutar ao
ver um ted como esse ou ler um artigo eu
vou preferir ted porque vai estimular
mais regiões no cérebro
além disso toque em suas emoções cria
histórias histórias elas escravizam a
concentração do nosso cérebro já
perceberam que eles têm muito mais
histórias nossas propagandas hoje do que
existia há um tempo atrás e que hoje
praticamente não se apresenta promoções
ou produtos mas se contam histórias
porque toda vez que o teu cérebro
percebe que alguma promoção está
acontecendo ele automaticamente
desconecta daquele conteúdo mas quando
alguma história tá passando na televisão
você não consegue não focar porque
aquilo ali estimula os sentimentos os
teus pensamentos a tua imaginação a tua
visão e audição então muitas áreas são
geradas são impactadas no teu cérebro e
por isso você não consegue encontrar o
se desconectar o terceiro atalho é faça
avaliações e julgamentos e eu indico
isso quando você não tiver outra opção a
não ser ler o conteúdo
então após ler o conteúdo faça análises
avaliações julgamentos porque ao fazer
isso você utiliza outras regiões o seu
cérebro e não apenas a região da leitura
e isso prova o convenci o cérebro que
vale a pena a armazenar aquele conteúdo
e por fim eu quero falar sobre eu quero
apresentar o atalho que é sempre que
possível fale em voz alta e simule uma
conversa ou uma apresentação sobre o
conteúdo
quando você fala você está utilizando
uma área do cérebro que geralmente não
utilizamos durante o aprendizado dessa
forma o cérebro percebe que é muito
importante que você está fazendo naquele
momento e assim ele vai dar a
importância vai aprender com facilidade
e é justamente baseado nesse último
atalho
o que eu quero pedir a vocês que fez com
partilha essa ideia porque eu peço isso
primeiro porque assim você vai ativar
outra vez no seu cérebro e você vai
conseguir aprender com mais clareza e
mais profundidade e percentual entre a
tona essa memória que nós estamos
falando aqui hoje esse conteúdo que
estamos falando aqui hoje para o segundo
motivo é porque ao passar adiante essa
idéia você estará também ajudando outras
pessoas para estarem prontas para o novo
amanhã eu apresentei aqui a minha ideia
para o novo amanhã mas não espero não
vamos chegar
comece a hackear o aprendizado desde
agora
desde hoje porque amanhã é o lugar para
onde nós queremos ir
na verdade o amanhã é o lugar que
estamos construindo a partir de agora
obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]